europe's borders whether it's traveling
through them or sharing information
across them is the big theme of this
week's meeting of justice and home
affairs ministers in brussels
the ministers are set to adopt decisions
bringing the powerful schengen database
sys2 into operation on april 9.
the computer allows border authorities
and police to share information on
people and lost or stolen goods it will
be able to use biometrics and have new
alert systems while better protecting
personal data ministers will also
examine the state of play concerning
bulgaria and romania's entry into the
schengen passport-free area
the european commission is set to unveil
to ministers its smart borders package
which will speed the entry of business
travelers researchers and students who
live outside europe
the system will record the data of all
foreign nationals when they enter and
leave
in the wake of the conflict in mali and
the hostage crisis in algeria the eu's
counter terrorism coordinator jill de
kirkhof will brief the ministers on the
extent of the threat and propose ways to
tackle this growing security problem in
northern africa the first message for
the minister of interior is to make sure
that they will make their resource
available that they have they are ready
to
send good police officers good
prosecutors experts on borders
experts on prevention of radicalization
to the different initiatives which are
launched by their colleagues minister
foreign affairs in mali not only in mali
in the whole region
on friday justice ministers will discuss
a proposal for a general framework to
protect data ensuring that this security
safety net keeps up with globalization
and the rapid advances of technology
they will also exchange views on better
ways to prevent counterfeiting of the
euro and other currencies and confirm a
new text on improving the protection of
victims of domestic violence